Trascrizione:
Buonasera a tutti.
Allora, io sono Manuel.
Oggi sono qui, in realtà,
non tanto per parlarvi di quella
che è poi la mia storia,
perché quella -
Basta, penso, cercare il mio nome
su internet e qualcosa esce, ok?
Io vi posso solamente dire, semmai,
che sono da sempre, e posso dire
veramente da sempre, un atleta
perché la mia prima gara, pensate,
l'ho fatta a cinque anni,
quindi so cosa vuol dire
essere un vero atleta;
e che - niente, come tutti i ragazzi
avevo un sogno, un sogno normalissimo:
quello di arrivare, un giorno, a vincere -
perché non mi bastava solo partecipare -
volevo vincere le Olimpiadi.
E questo sogno
è stato un attimo interrotto
da una piccola cosa
che è successa un paio di anni fa,
ovvero per sbaglio,
uno scambio di persona,
una sera in un pub, fuori da un pub,
un colpo di pistola, un proiettile
mi ha preso per sbaglio
e mi ha costretto a questa
condizione temporanea,
però che vivo adesso, ecco.
Quindi, la mia vita
da quel giorno è cambiata.
Ho detto: bene, sono rinato
perché ho iniziato
una vera e propria nuova vita.
Però oggi non è di me che voglio parlare,
lo potete cercare.
Io vorrei parlare, più che altro,
di quella che è la mia storia
e si unisce a quella di tutti voi, ok?
Perché, se ci pensiamo bene...
Ok, a me è successa una cosa
sicuramente grave, grande, bruttissima,
però alla fine può essere,
in scala ridotta,
quello che succede a noi,
a noi tutti, tutti i giorni.
Quindi una difficoltà,
un ostacolo, un problema,
una qualsiasi cosa
da affrontare nella vita.
Quello che ci tengo a sottolineare, però,
è che per me i problemi
possono essere, ovviamente,
molto grandi e di diverso tipo,
però in realtà per voi può essere
anche il fidanzato che vi lascia,
prendere un brutto voto a scuola,
oppure il lavoro che va male;
può essere, veramente, una qualsiasi cosa,
perché ogni persona,
visto che siamo tutti diversi,
ognuno di noi vive i propri problemi,
i propri sentimenti, le proprie difficoltà
a peso proprio.
Quindi non mi sento di dire
che io ho dei problemi diversi dai vostri
e sono peggiori, migliori:
assolutamente, siamo tutti diversi,
e ognuno di noi vive
quella che è la sua realtà
a peso proprio,
questo voglio sottolinearlo.
Partendo da questo,
per collegarci alla parola di oggi,
alla fine tutti noi abbiamo
a che fare, quotidianamente,
o avremmo avuto a che fare,
o avremo, un giorno,
a che fare con il caos.
Ecco, questa parola che tanto
ci mette poi in difficoltà
durante quella situazione che viviamo.
Io posso dirvi, semplicemente,
dato che sono veramente
un ragazzo come voi,
come io faccio,
come io posso approcciarmi
a una situazione, sicuramente,
difficile da affrontare.
Perché se ce la faccio io,
che sono normalissimo,
ce la potete fare tutti voi.
Il semplice caos, secondo me,
va visto un po' come un momento
in cui bisogna fermarsi
un attimo a pensare,
e sì, cercare di rifare
un attimo un ordine di idee,
rimettere in sesto tutto quanto.
Ok, mi trovo in questa situazione:
cosa faccio? Faccio ordine.
E adesso ve lo faccio capire
con una metafora molto semplice.
Se voi, prima di uscire,
dovete andare nell'armadio,
spesso è tutto in ordine
tranne il cassetto dei calzini,
che non si sa mai
perché è sempre un casino.
Dovete uscire e dovete prendere
dei calzini uguali.
Sicuramente, se c'è
un grande caos, lì dentro,
ci metterete una vita a trovarli uguali,
farete fatica, troverete
delle soluzioni a caso,
ovvero tirate fuori
un sacco di calzini diversi:
insomma, non trovate quello che vi serve.
Se invece voi, per un attimo,
pensate di mettere
in ordine, quel cassetto,
quando vi ritroverete a uscire
dalla porta di casa in fretta,
e quindi ad avere una cosa
da dover sistemare al volo,
come un problema.
quel cassetto lo aprite
e trovate subito la soluzione,
perché è in ordine.
Tutto è messo bene, in ordine,
tutto è ben chiaro.
Questo sicuramente vi aiuterà e vi sarà -
e vi farà risparmiare un sacco di tempo,
un sacco di energie,
e magari, visto che ce la farete
così rapidamente,
vi accorgerete di calzini
che neanche pensavate di avere.
Nella vita, magari,
la stessa cosa può essere
che avendo un ordine chiaro delle cose,
vi potrete accorgere di avere dei valori,
di avere delle persone
e delle fortune affianco a voi
che magari prima davate
un po' per scontato.
Perché purtroppo,
mi rendo conto anche io,
nella mia vita precedente,
ho dato spesso per scontato
cose che in realtà ora sono fondamentali,
come lo stare bene,
lo stare bene tra la famiglia,
tra le persone;
e quando mi chiedono
cosa sogno per il futuro,
magari avrei detto un'Olimpiade,
avrei detto un sacco
di cose materiali, chissà;
invece, adesso, l'unica cosa che chiedo
è sperare di trovarmi tra anni in salute,
e sapere che magari alzo il telefono
e c'è mamma ancora,
dall'altra parte, a rispondere,
sapere di avere una famiglia
che sta bene, stare in salute.
Questo perché ho fatto ordine di idee,
ho messo in scala di priorità
le cose più importanti
secondo me nella vita.
E mi sono reso conto
che sono molto fortunato
a poter vivere tutte queste cose, ecco.
Questa è un'altra cosa
che io consiglio sempre di fare,
cercare di mettere
sul piatto della bilancia
tutte quelle cose che voi avete,
dalle quali potete ripartire
dopo un momento difficile, no?
Se voi pensate a un problema,
o pensate a un ostacolo da affrontare,
la prima cosa che dovete fare
è proprio quella,
cercare di capire da dove partire,
e da dove partire
lo trovate solo, e solamente,
da tutte le cose che già avete,
che magari date per scontate,
ma che in realtà sono, diciamo,
la base vera e fondamentale
per partire, ecco.
E questo vi aiuta tanto,
perché vi porterà sicuramente
ad avere, a raggiungere poi,
quella situazione di consapevolezza
per quanto riguarda il futuro,
perché mi rendo conto
che al giorno d'oggi,
in un mondo come quello di oggi,
è sicuramente difficile
fare dei piani nel futuro,
pensare lontano, a cosa
si desidera, a cosa si vuole,
quando in realtà basta una pandemia
e si ferma quasi il mondo:
no, si ferma a tutti gli effetti.
Noi però, secondo me,
se pensiamo di arrivare al nostro futuro
con tanta consapevolezza dentro,
sono sicuro che vi aiuterà
non a evitare il problema,
perché quello arriverà,
però avrete la consapevolezza
che vi permetterà di dire:
questo già l'avevo
messo in preventivo, ok?
Se noi non pensiamo più di vivere
nell'illusione che tutto
andrà sempre bene,
ma ci fermiamo un attimo a pensare
che nella vita le cose
potranno pure andare male,
è normale, fa parte del gioco,
ecco, noi -
Nel momento in cui andranno male,
andranno male uguale;
ma sapremo che sarebbe andata anche così,
saremo più pronti anche a quel momento lì.
E questa è una cosa
molto importante, secondo me,
è diventato proprio il mio stile di vita,
il sapere che, ok,
io posso sognare in grande,
posso sognare quello che voglio,
ma devo tenere conto
di quella che è la realtà,
di non vivere sempre e comunque
in un'illusione, appunto,
che tutto vada bene.
E credetemi che una volta
che riuscite a fare questo passo,
vivrete sicuramente
molto, molto più sereni;
e vorrei sottolineare
che per fare questo passo
io ci ho messo più di un anno,
non è stato immediato.
Questo è importantissimo,
perché è molto facile parlare,
mi rendo conto,
a parole siamo bravi tutti, no?
Poi nel concreto è difficile
fare le cose, me ne rendo conto.
Però, per esperienza personale,
vi posso dire che si può fare;
e si può fare come? Ci vuole il suo tempo,
come ogni cosa, a suo tempo.
Ed è importantissimo, secondo me,
prenderci del tempo
da dedicare a queste sensazioni
che ci fanno vivere sereni:
e dico sereni non per sbaglio,
ma perché se vi dicessi di vivere felici
sarebbe veramente stupido.
Anche a me lo chiedono spesso: sei felice?
E io posso dirti, in questo momento:
no, perché sto vivendo
una situazione brutta;
però sono sereno.
È quello l'importante,
la differenza tra felicità e serenità.
Noi dobbiamo cercare la serenità
per poter durare più a lungo
in modo sereno,
in modo da poter affrontare la vita,
con tutte le sfide che ci porrà davanti,
nel migliore dei modi.
Perché tanto lo sappiamo,
dalla mia esperienza si può imparare
che la vita non è
quello che pensiamo di fare,
è quello che ti capita
nel momento in cui non ci pensi.
Ecco, quindi la cosa più importante
è raggiungere quella serenità,
e consapevolezza,
che vi porterà ad affrontare il problema
nel migliore dei modi,
e questo credo sia importantissimo.
Poi ci sono -
Siamo tutti diversi, ripeto,
quindi sicuramente tutti noi, qui dentro,
affrontiamo un ostacolo in modo diverso.
Io, per esempio,
posso dirvi come faccio io.
Io, per esempio, se ho un problema
la prima cosa che faccio
non è di sicuro nasconderlo.
Assolutamente, mio padre
mi conosce, lo sa,
lo vede lontano, penso, tre chilometri.
È proprio perché io
mi faccio travolgere dalla situazione,
e questo perché?
Se io mi faccio travolgere
da una situazione negativa,
arriva il momento in cui sono,
magari, sul letto da solo,
triste, affranto,
distrutto da tutti i pensieri;
però poi arriva il momento
in cui ho quel pensiero che mi dice,
ti rendi conto che hai
la fortuna più grande:
di esser vivo, di poter vivere.
Quindi lo faccio apposta,
quello di farmi travolgere
da tutti questi pensieri negativi
per poter poi, alla fine,
semplicemente dirmi:
muoviti, sei ancora vivo, e puoi farcela.
Questo per farvi capire
che, assolutamente, io credo sia sbagliato
dover nascondere un sentimento negativo
per vergogna, per un milione
di altri motivi.
E ha citato prima il film,
e su questo io cito un'altra frase
che disse [Ral]: "Non sempre
puoi salvarti da solo".
Anche questo credo
veramente sia fondamentale,
perché se io sono qui, come sono adesso,
non è per un percorso
che ho fatto pienamente da solo.
Io ho preso un qualcosa
da tutte le persone
che mi sono state vicine
e ho imparato, ho imparato
a essere semplicemente me stesso,
che è la cosa più importante.
Quello che io consiglio veramente
di fare, a tutti quanti,
è di valorizzare le persone vere
che avete al vostro fianco
e di trarre tutto quello
che di più positivo potete trarre,
perché alla fine abbiamo sempre
da imparare un po' da chiunque,
come spero di aver insegnato
qualcosa anche io a qualcuno.
Questo è quello che io cerco di fare
con persone di qualsiasi tipo,
di qualsiasi età, di qualsiasi genere,
perché è la cosa, penso sia -
Quando trovi poi questo equilibrio,
questo modo di vivere,
voi riuscite a vivere
tutto quello che avrete davanti,
cose belle e brutte,
in modo unico, veramente.
Io, se dovessi pensare
a come vivo adesso le mie giornate,
sembra assurdo, perché è un modo di dire,
ma vivo tutti i giorni
come se fossero l'ultimo,
perché sei sereno, sei tranquillo, ecco.
E l'ultima cosa che ci tenevo a dire
che è molto, molto importante,
è proprio quella di -
quella che racchiude quelli che sono
i nostri sogni, le nostre passioni.
E anche qui, non esistono età,
non esiste che bisogna parlare di sogni
solo ai bambini o ai ragazzi, insomma,
perché tutte le persone
sono sempre in tempo
per poter realizzare i propri sogni,
le proprie cose, e i propri desideri.
Ecco, oggi se voi vi fermate un attimo
a pensare cosa sognate, cosa volete,
molto probabilmente
penserete che sia impossibile;
e io me ne rendo conto
perché lo vivo anch'io:
adesso sogno di tornare a camminare,
e magari ora è impossibile.
Però se io questo sogno
che vedo così lontano
lo faccio -
Lo cerco di tenere,
vedere il più vicino possibile,
mettendomi degli step,
degli step che rendono il sogno,
il desiderio una cosa più realistica,
visto che il sogno è sempre
una cosa molto immaginaria,
ecco che ogni volta
che io supererò un piccolo step,
questo sogno mi sembrerà
sempre più vicino.
Bisogna sapersi accontentare
di piccole cose, dei piccoli traguardi,
delle piccole cose
e delle piccole emozioni.
Una cosa che, forse,
si è un po' persa nell'ultimo periodo;
Però, ecco, io credo che sia fondamentale
avere la voglia, soprattutto,
di mettersi in gioco,
perché io, dopo quello che mi è successo,
ho avuto tante persone
che non smetterò mai di ringraziare
che mi sono state vicine.
Però, proprio per quello ho capito
che una cosa, se io la voglio,
la devo volere io a tutti i costi.
perché possono dirmelo
infinte persone affianco,
"Devi fare questo perché sei portato",
"Vai alle Olimpiadi,
ce la fai, sei forte":
ma se non lo voglio io,
non accadrà mai, ok?
Quindi tutto parte sempre e solo
da voi, nel vostro piccolo.
E come ultimissima cosa
che ci tengo di cuore a dire,
è sempre, lo ripeto a chiunque,
è che -
Noi tutti adesso
stiamo vivendo una vita, no?
Una vita della quale...
Insomma, non sappiamo ancora,
ovviamente, cosa ci riserva.
Ecco, io vi invito a provare
qualsiasi cosa che sentite
di voler provare,
ovviamente cose positive,
perché adesso, magari, in questa sala
tra tutti noi ci sta
la più grande violinista del mondo,
ma questa ragazza, questo ragazzo,
se non ha mai preso un violino in mano
come fa a saperlo, questo?
Ecco, io questo -
È successo così col mio pianoforte:
io ho suonato la batteria per una vita,
ma un pianoforte non l'avevo mai toccato;
ma me ne sono subito innamorato,
e adesso sto vivendo grazie a lui
tantissime emozioni,
bellissime e fortissime,
che, se non l'avessi mai toccato,
non avrei mai vissuto.
Quindi il mio invito
è quello di provare, di credere
e di non smettere mai di sognare
e di rendere i vostri sogni
più concreti possibili,
per un futuro pieno di consapevolezza
e di voglia di fare,
perché possiamo farcela tutti quanti.